[Music]
you are looking at Augusta National Golf
Club this morning where Tiger Woods is
hoping to make history we're just vying
Forest record tying sixth green jacket
in the master tournament this weekend
that will put him on par with the
current record holder Tech Nicholas CBS
Sports will broadcast the Masters for
the 68th consecutive year Augusta
National Golf Club chairman Fred Ridley
just officially began the tournament
along with golf greats Nicholas Gary
Player and Tom Watson at the honorary
starter ceremony take a look
good morning
my name is Fred Ridley
and on behalf of the membership of
Augusta National Golf Club it is my
pleasure to welcome you to the 87th
playing of the Masters Tournament thank
you all for being with us
today I have the honor of introducing
three Legendary Champions
they have won a combined 11 Green
Jackets
and made an incredible
140 appearances through six decades in
the Masters Tournament
this morning we add another Milestone to
their history at Augusta National
first on the T it is my great pleasure
to welcome back golf's preeminent Global
ambassador
the Masters tournament's First
International Champion with three Green
Jackets
from South Africa
please welcome Mr Gary Player
Gary playway please
next
[Applause]
60 years after his first Green Jacket we
proudly welcome back our six-time
Masters champion and one of golf's great
icons
whose historic record at the Masters has
provided some of the tournament's most
unforgettable moments ladies and
gentlemen Mr Jack Nicholas
[Laughter]
that's the hardest part of it I promise
you okay
oh okay
hopefully goodbye ball
[Applause]
well done Jack
now on the tee we welcome back
two-time Masters champion
an eight-time major champion
known around the world not only for his
outstanding play but for his remarkable
longevity
and Legacy in the game
please welcome Mr Tom Watson
[Applause]
that's not the normal hand I Tee It Up
with
you don't ride go-karts at my age
yeah you do
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the 2023 Masters is
now officially underway enjoy the
tournament
foreign
us now from Augusta CBS Sports is Jim
Nance he's covering the Masters for the
38th year in a row alongside lead golf
analyst Trevor immelman who won this
golf tournament in 2008 good morning
fellas how are you doing
morning morning great to be joining you
good morning Nate I saw your golf
segment before your commentary and we
need to work on vlad's putting stroke a
little bit okay I
let's start with you tiger is vying for
the sixth green jacket and that would
tie him with Jack Nicholas what are you
looking at when it comes to Tigers game
well he doesn't play Much Anymore Nate
we know that this is uh unfortunately
they're just uh rare appearances because
of his uh of his health and the injuries
suffered in the car crash a couple of
years ago but he he played in Los
Angeles uh made the cut had a fabulous
third round I think listen everything he
does
is freakish what he could do but he had
he just this could be really tough for
him the weather this weekend is going to
be cold damp wet it's going to be hard
for him I think to just walk the course
that's the biggest concern for him but
you never put anything past him I'll put
it that way but he's clearly not one of
the top 20 favorites right now as we we
start the tournament today
Tim I want to spin it forward but I have
to ask you you saw a tiger in his prime
what was that like when you were
witnessing greatness
he won 57 of his 82 tournaments on CBS
he won nine of his 15 Majors on our air
that's a lot of times to document
greatness and first off he was just able
to out-think everybody he outworked
everyone and it's one of the great
Thrills of my career is to be able to
document so many of those Tiger Woods
moments and who knows maybe there's
another one what he did here in 2019 it
just uh the world was in all when he had
his return to glory and again I never
sell them shorts so I'm looking for uh
very closely what he'll do today he's
off at about an hour and a half his
first round starts shortly after 10
o'clock here Eastern Time
and we always love to watch him Jim now
Trevor I know that you spoke with tiger
as well as with some other Masters
winners for a special 13 Green Jackets
which airs this Saturday on CBS and
Paramount plus what did you take away
from that conversation especially as a
golfer yourself who won that tournament
there
yeah it was just such a treat for me to
be able to spend time with three Legends
like that you got the defending champion
in Scottish Scheffler current world
number one but then the two greatest
players to ever walk the planet in Jack
Nicklaus and Tiger Woods and the thing
that I really took away from that
experience was you know they just like
the rest of us they're just like any
golfers out there when they were in the
same room together they love giving each
other the needle giving each other a
hard time about the different shots and
and situations we were talking about and
uh it really was fun for me to be a part
of that and see these great Champions
just let their guard down a little bit
and enjoy talking about a golf course in
Augusta National and a tournament in the
Masters that we all love so much
uh Jim it's Vlad so everybody obviously
is looking towards Rory McIlroy he's
looking to make history this weekend but
what are some of the other players we
should be looking at
well Scotty shuffler won it last year's
only been three occasions now Vlad where
we've had somebody go back to back and
um legendary names Jack Nicholas Nick
Faldo and Tiger Woods but his game right
now is all systems go I would not be
surprised to see him make a run at it
you mentioned McElroy that's the richest
stories going for the career Grand Slam
I think he's going to be right there on
Sunday and then you got John rum to me
as the next guy you talk about uh
dominated early in the year seems like a
custom fit for this Spain has produced
players that have a fabulous record
Around Augusta and I just got to think
one of these years it's his time
Trevor we have to go but quickly as a
golfer who who's hit the green and won
the jacket what's your bit of advice to
those that are going to golf this
weekend
well they're just going to hang have to
hang in there and be very very patient
Nate we we the weather forecast right
now is not looking ideal the wind
direction is going to be switching all
over the place during the four days of
the tournament we have chances of
thunderstorms cooler temperatures on the
weekend with higher winds so players are
going to have to hold that patience be
unflappable so to speak they're going to
have so many different things thrown at
them on a very difficult golf course I
cannot wait to watch and see it how it
unfolds yeah we can't wait to watch and
watch your coverage gymnast and travel
and women thank you so much here's the
rundown of all the Masters action here
on CBS today and tomorrow we'll bring
you all the highlights at 11 35 p.m
third round coverage begins Saturday at
3 P.M Eastern noon Pacific that does it
for us here we will see you tomorrow on
CBS mornings